led licht hat ausgerechnet gravierende
schädliche folgen warnt ein
forschungsteam aus potsdam
die erde wird immer heller die folgen
davon dass die nacht zunehmend
verschwindet es sind nicht nur deutlich
weniger sternzeichen ende zu sehen
sondern auch tiere und wir menschen
bekommen das zu spüren
wie genau und was jeder einzelne von uns
gegen die zunehmende lichtverschmutzung
tun kann jetzt den klicks um
science-fiction herzlich willkommen
vielen dank für die zahlreichen
genesungswünsche ich denke ich bin
wieder auf dem aufsteigenden ast fakt
ist wir menschen machen die erde nicht
nur wärmer wir machen sie auch heller
genau das zeigen jetzt ergebnisse eines
forschungsteams vom geoforschungszentrum
potsdam
dabei stützen sie sich auf
messergebnisse des us-satelliten sony
ngp der ein radiometer an bord hat den
820 kilometern höhe misst er sowohl das
licht das wir menschen sehen können als
auch die für uns unsichtbaren emissionen
die sich im nahen infrarotbereich
befinden die daten auflösung liegt bei
750 metern die weltweite nicht
verschmutzung kann somit sehr genau
erfasst werden und trotzdem das problem
der zunehmenden helligkeit wird von der
aktuellen studie eher unter als
überschätzt denn das messgerät sony ngp
miss licht mit wellenlänge von 500
nanometern aufwärts neuere leds
beinhalten mittlerweile aber bereits
licht mit wellenlängen unter diesem wert
das ist also noch nicht in diesen
messungen enthalten die ergebnisse der
studie in den letzten fünf jahren haben
sowohl die bestrahlten fläche als auch
die intensität der künstlichen
beleuchtung zugenommen jeweils
mindestens um zwei prozent dieser trend
ist fast in allen ländern zu beobachten
abgesehen von regionen dieser welt in
den krieg herrscht so wie etwa in syrien
oder dem jemen ein weiteres ergebnis des
potsdamer forschungsteams die zunahme
der lichtverschmutzung entspricht in
etwa dem maß in dem auch das
bruttosozialprodukt eines landes wächst
in industrieländern ist dies etwas
langsamer der fall als in schwellen-
oder entwicklungsländern schuld daran
sind eben die leds selbst wenn sie in
der anschaffung erst einmal teurer sind
als klassische natriumdampflampen gelten
sie als langlebiger zudem auch als
heller und gleichzeitig
die sparen dementsprechend wird weltweit
umgerüstet städte firmen und privatleute
setzen zunehmend auf diese art der
beleuchtung hier vermutet das potsdamer
forschungsteam den sogenannten rebound
effekt eigentlich wenn man etwas gutes
tun
doch das verkehrt sich dann ins
gegenteil die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler gehen davon aus dass
durch den zunehmenden einsatz von led
licht jetzt auch orte und dinge
beleuchtet werden die früher nicht
beleuchtet worden sind mögliche
einsparungen werden also durch den
zusätzlichen einsatz von leds sowie dazu
nicht gemacht und sogar überkompensiert
zitat obwohl einzelne projekte energie
einsparen wird der einspareffekt durch
neue projekte auf rezept das sagt einer
der beteiligten forscher christoph huber
vergleichbar mit einem autofahrer der
sich ein extra umweltfreundliches modell
kauft das wenig benzin verbraucht dann
aber weitere strecken zurücklegt und
somit der natur schadet auch ein
beispiel für diesen rebound effekt die
folgen also des steigenden led einsatzes
die nacht verschwindet die erde wird
heller gravieren für nachtaktive tiere
die sich so immer schlechter orientieren
können aber auch störungen in der
fortpflanzung wir im hormonhaushalt oder
der nahrungssuche können die folgen sein
und auch für uns menschen ist der
wechsel von tag und nacht also
helligkeit und dunkelheit enorm wichtig
doch led-licht gaukelt uns
beispielsweise in der nacht vor er sei
bereits morgen und so kann unsere innere
uhr aus dem gleichgewicht geraten und
darüber haben wir ja hier erst vor
kurzem im rahmen der nobelpreis woche
berichtet die innere uhr hat deutlich
mehr einfluss auf den menschlichen
körper als sie vielleicht denken mag
wenn die zellen aller lebewesen
reagieren sehr sensibel auf
veränderungen wie die folge von hell und
dunkel warm und kalt die
körpertemperatur steigt und sinkt
beispielsweise und auf unser
hormonspiegel ändert sich wir alle
kennen diese art jetlag gefühl durch die
zeitumstellung im frühjahr wenn wir
plötzlich eine stunde früher aufstehen
müssen und der stoffwechsel
durcheinander gerät fatale also welche
konsequenzen die zunehmende
lichtverschmutzung für alle lebewesen
auf der erde haben könnte doch die gute
nachricht jeder von uns kann etwas
dagegen machen und das ist gar nicht mal
so schwer
wer uns das problem erst einmal bewusst
machen und das licht ausschalten wenn
wir es gerade eben nicht benötigen
der erste schritt schon einmal getan der
kanton zürich hat noch mehr tipps
zusammengefasst
grundsätzlich ist es besser wenn man das
licht von oben nach unten ausrichtet und
nicht umgekehrt sieht tatsächlich auch
das nicht präzise zu lenken oder es
präzise zu steuern beispielsweise indem
man einen bewegungsmelder verwendet aber
es gibt auch noch einen weiteren tipp
von christoph huber aus dem potsdamer
forschungsteam für die meisten von uns
ist nicht etwas dass da ist und über das
man sich keine gedanken gemacht aber
wenn es da eine lampe in ihrer stadt
gibt die sie stört zum beispiel weil sie
zu hell ist rufen sie ihre stadtwerke an
und vielleicht könnt ihr dann was tun
wenn er kein video zum thema noch zu
allen anderen themen verpassen wollt
dann durch meliert ein abo aufs auge und
vergesst nicht den auf die glocke hier
geht es weiter mit dafür draufklicken
smarthome die zukunft des lebens mit
noch mehr infos dazu wie man bequemer
leben und sparen kann
und ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran